- [Narrator] Made entirely of
wood without a single nail,
the Sanctuary of Truth
in Pattaya, Thailand,
is a modern-day marvel built
using ancient carving techniques.
This religious shrine has
been under construction
since 1981,
and it isn't scheduled to
be completed anytime soon.
It was commissioned by a Thai millionaire,
who spent his fortune
on projects like this.
He wanted to keep ancient
wood-building techniques alive.
The building towers 375 feet,
and looks out over the coast.
Its four wings are dedicated
to Thai, Cambodian,
Chinese, and Indian iconography.
A team of 250 wood carvers
have created ornate images
of religious and
philosophical significance
throughout the structure.
The Sanctuary of Truth is
considered an art installation,
religious shrine, and
cultural monument, all in one.
Although the creator has
passed away and won't have
an opportunity to see his
celestial masterpiece completed,
the work continues according
to his specific plans.